from newsweek texas could vote to secede
from the u.s in 2023 as gop pushes for
referendum
the texas republicans are pushing for a
referendum to decide whether the state
should secede from the u.s the demand
for texans to be allowed to vote on the
issue in 2023 was one of many measures
adopted in texas gop's party platform
following last week's state convention
in houston now i want to point out it's
not the first time someone's called for
this but it seems to be moving forward
under a section titled state sovereignty
the platform states pursuant to article
1 section 1 of the texas constitution
the federal government has impaired our
right to local self-government therefore
federally mandated legislation that
infringes upon the 10th amendment rights
of texas should be ignored opposed
refused and nullified
texas retains the right to secede from
the u.s and the texas legislature should
be called upon to pass a referendum
consistent there too
now let me ask you with all of these
libertarian types moving to texas yep do
you think there's going to be increasing
support for texas succession oh
absolutely the national libertarian
party just passed a platform change in
support of secession and the florida
state libertarian party did earlier this
year we're we're all about it because we
think that people should be able to live
their own lives and just peacefully
separate
we emphasis on peaceful you know but uh
well then then then maybe there's a real
possibility for dissolution like the
soviet union as opposed to the civil war
that's what i'm hoping for and and i'm
hoping that even if it takes a little
bit longer that we could do that and
even if it's not a hundred percent
are you actually hoping for it are you
saying
instead of violence you'd rather it be
peaceful because i'm saying any
dissolution of the us is a bad thing
i'm trying to look at it realistically
which is i don't know how we can come
together
as americans
when we fundamentally have so many major
disagreements well it's not
shared values
that is keeping us together anymore it's
decadence and how comfortable we've
gotten yeah how fat and happy they're
keeping us and frankly
pop culture that they're feeding us and
no one wants to go to war because war is
awful yeah and and the people who fought
a civil war before were
made of much tougher stuff yeah
absolutely realistically it's not we're
not talking about whether it would be a
good or a bad thing it would never
happen
or maybe i'm just like operating on the
the principle that nothing ever happens
well
well yeah that optimism bias well that's
that's normalcy bias it it's it's it's
doesn't happen it's not going to happen
but uh
you know like it's what ian was saying
earlier that these people don't actually
want civil war and i agree they don't
know what civil war is right but when
you see these anti-for people going
around with guns
and and shooting people like the dude in
portland got shot it doesn't matter if
you're tough it matters if you're dumb
it matters if you know
uh forest cooper was on the show last
week and he said the people who are good
at violence aren't doing it and you have
to ask yourself why that is
because because we know how awful it is
well you know the people who have
trained in war who know how to do war
are staying away from the stuff because
they don't right they know how bad it is
but the people who are engaging in it
don't know don't care
i'll tell you once it comes they'll
regret it but by then it's too late
so
i was reading this great post so let me
tell you something do you know what
bourgeois bourgeoisie bourgeoisie means
bourgeois
the actual definition no do you know
anybody it just makes me think of
hoity-toity wealth wealthy rich people
wrongs middle class i think yeah it's
middle class yeah is it the proletariat
that's uh that's the working class then
who's the upper class what do they call
them i don't know
i don't know all i know is the bourgeois
bougie it means middle class
so when these when these people these
people understand is these like antifa
urban liberal types
they're the people who get purged in the
communist revolution yeah they're the
bad ones there was this is meme post
where they're like a bunch of trump q
and on rednecks are going to team up
with inner city gangs because they have
more in common than the laptop class
yeah with each other than the laptop
class and so there's going to be these
uppity hipsters who want to eat vegan
food wondering you know what's going on
and the people who literally have
nothing are going to be like you are the
people whose wealth we will redistribute
yes and the rich people who have all
their money in panama and switzerland
are going to laugh and be like can't do
anything to me well that's a common part
of critical theory and marxism is that
the middle class is what has kept the
proletariat from rising up
and defeating and trying to trying to
overthrow the upper classes because they
see the middle class as oh that's so
attainable i want to move to that i want
to become that i bring that up though
because i think you made a good point
mary
that what's holding this country
together is basically everybody's fat
and happy and doesn't want to risk their
krispy kremes in their marvel movies
i prefer not to i prefer to not be shot
in the street that sounds like a
horrible time well i mean like
that's the worst of it but even your
movie theater being shut down it sucked
yeah like entertainment is getting worse
our food is poison
so
if they can't even keep up the
appearance that we're comfortable and
distracted
i understand why some people's minds are
going towards
civil strife at the very least or
civil war i i think i i think civil war
i'm pretty sure that
the lockdowns contributed to a large
part of the rioting because people were
they didn't have anything else to do
oh yeah i think i think you lock someone
in a cubicle apartment yeah this is the
crazy thing man um i think for for most
conservatives who live in suburbs and in
rural areas they don't understand
that in new york city you're in a 15 by
15 box and you cannot leave
these people were effectively in
solitary confinement yeah and then all
of a sudden you see people in the
streets running around smashing stuff
you're there the city went nuts there's
nothing else to do
well it's the one time you can go
outside yeah that's a scary thing it's
really sad the question i suppose is
you know texas talks about succeeding a
whole lot actually going to do it or
well we'll see so i think that this is
probably going to get tied up in a legal
battle and and and it's going to end up
just like the supreme court and so yeah
it's going to be secession 2.0 that's
the one that you have to watch for is
how do they react after they get smacked
down and ignored by the powers that be
well i think
what uh
what we should look out for is exactly
what happened in the first civil war
texas says these other states aren't
dividing by the law they've already said
that this people need to pay attention
to this okay
look at the chronology of the civil war
the southern state said the north was
not abiding by the law because they
weren't adhering to the fugitive slave
act
not a fan of that my in my opinion the
fugitive slave act was if the slave
escapes the north has to return them but
the north certainly wasn't doing that
and i'm like okay that's a good thing
they shouldn't have but the state the
south then said if you aren't abiding by
the laws we agreed on there's no union
anyway so the federal government was not
adhering to the law and not enforcing it
so then they said okay we succeeded
the supreme court can say whatever they
want if texas is outright saying this
election is illegitimate it's the gop
saying it yes but if texas
the ag filed a lawsuit and he did the
state of texas did
and the supreme court refused to hear it
we're getting to the point where you
have a state saying you are not abiding
by the law how close are we until texas
just says we don't care what the federal
government thinks we're not asking for
for permission
hopefully we're getting close
okay but i mean it's a scary prospect
but let's think about is going to come
in what if uh
is china going to cut with what nuclear
submarines off the coast
yeah i don't know about i don't know i
don't know about invasion drop bombs on
why would they do that
just to take control of it but they will
bomb them that would be terrible who
would buy them texas i believe that the
federal government would absolutely it's
not a federal it's not a united states
state at that point this is where i'm
talking about post-secession okay if the
state's defense there's nothing like
post-secession see i don't think that
it'll happen that quickly i think that
what's going to happen if we have a
secession movement that really takes
takes hold is that you're going to start
to see the federal government become
more hands-off but you're still going to
see military bases and
alphabet agencies still there still
active but you're just going to start to
see the rest of the influence decline
i think if texas secedes then you're
going to have states in the union who
say we need access to x resource now
normally we deal with texas but now
there's a border and there are new
regulations popping up and new
negotiations to be had
china then comes in and says we're going
to give you that resource 10 off
and they go you got it much more likely
to go about things that way and then
within 10 years they're completely
dependent upon china the texas industry
of oil or whatever they're producing
gets gutted and destroyed because
china's got more ability to go like
but think about texas culture like how
likely do you think they are to be like
china come on over
well they won't though but california
will california is going to be like it's
way cheaper to buy from china yes but
but then we'll see probably what we're
already seeing right now in europe which
is that people people tend to freak out
when you see another country a major
military power start to encroach on your
border and i think that the united
states even if texas completely seceded
would still keep a strong military
alliance with texas and if china started
doing anything uh particularly sketchy
i think the united states military would
lose their minds and and go to town i
look at all this stuff happening and i'm
just frustrated by how stupid our
government is yeah because
the supreme
here's the problem it's a bunch of
cowards yeah they're all cowards the
republicans are cowards most the
democrats are cowards supreme court's a
bunch of cowards
so uh thomas and alito probably the only
people who have any backbone to them the
only ones were willing to hear that
texas lawsuit and they didn't issue a
ruling on the merits they just said
original jurisdictions lawsuits are
within our purview we must hear them
that's it yep the rest of them were like
no i don't want to be involved in this
oh i'm so scared not me right they don't
want to get swatted
yeah yeah you know if they just come out
and said we'll hear it you know we'll
hear it and then the supreme court could
have come out outright said
we reject it the states are allowed to
and hold their elections as they see fit
their vote has nothing to do with your
vote move on so the implication there is
that they didn't hear it
because they were afraid that the
country would freak out and people would
lose their minds if they gave
their honest opinions which just means
that two years later
the confidence in the election is
shattered the american people feel like
they're there's no regis of grievances
the first amendment is trash
and now here we go second amendment's in
the gutter fourth amendment in the
gutter fifth amendments in the gutter
you ever you look at the constitution
right now and you gotta wonder what
rights are are are are being protected
at all if any
you've got major corporations who have
taken political speech
now you've got a fracturing of american
culture based on the fact that people
could not gather and communicate anymore
because no one was willing to address
that issue or should have very least one
faction was suppressing the other and
you had a bunch of people uh in silicon
valley second amendment has been
infringed upon for the past hundred plus
years
in every possible way yeah it is
clear-cut the right of the people to
keep and bear arms the third amendment
mostly mostly not being infringed but
there was one issue of uh
the eviction moratorium yeah when the
federal government said that you
couldn't evict people there were
landlords who said my tenant is is is
active duty
that means the government is mandating i
keep an active duty service member in my
home that violates the third amendment
that was fascinating fourth amendment oh
come on
is there a fourth amendment we got stop
and frisk we got red flag laws already
in 19 states patriot act patriot act oh
come on you've got uh um the metadata
spawn get the nsa come on
look at all the x key score all those
things that were unveiled by edward
snowden and uh if they're if any
amendment has been crossed out so hard
it's been ripped from the paper itself
it's the fourth amendment yeah it's
toilet paper yeah fifth amendment oh
come on look at the ahmed aubry case
there's no there's there's no right to a
a trial anymore there's no innocent
until proven guilty patriot act again
patriot act again there you go and then
if you look at the 9th and 10th
amendments texas is right here now
there's a whole bunch of other
amendments we can talk about we can
still drink beer i guess we need we need
what gwyneth paltrow calls the conscious
uncoupling we need that from the federal
government is that what she said
that's one way to do it i guess uh luke
rudkowski last week i think it was made
a interesting um illusion between the
enabling act that hitler signed that
stripped the germans of their
rights to the patriot act and
i think that might actually be a lot
more realistic like the reichstag fire
reichstag was a burnt um hitler blamed
the communists and then immediately
seized people's rights the world trade
centers came down we immediately blamed
the muslims and osama bin laden and then
signed the patriot act i think you're
right i wish we could talk about hitler
and people would listen but that's not
they're listening no they're listening
well history doesn't repeat it rhymes as
saying goes yeah and so certainly there
are people who learn from history in
good ways and bad ways yeah you can
learn from mystery in the good way and
be like hey that was the thing that
happened it was bad and then everyone
suffered let's not do that again no it's
not other people can learn from the past
and bad ways where they're like you see
what that bad guy did that worked let's
try that you got to learn not to rush to
make legislation after a tragedy yeah no
no no no the the the politicians were
like we better rush to make legislation
after this tragedy is our only chance
yeah you look at the exploitation of a
crisis they do it every single as a just
citizen don't do it don't support
politicians that want to do it it's it's
crazy emotional power grab there's no
need to rush legislation
you've got to rush in war but you don't
need to rush the legislative that's what
career politicians do though this is
interesting right all the the crossover
between them and corporate journalists
because they got a rush to capitalize on
a crisis too everybody's like oh i got
to be the first one there it's pretty
great adam schiff came out and he was
like you know i have evidence that
donald trump was involved in january 6.
and then it was a dana bash i think
she was like what evidence well let's
not get ahead about the hearing here oh
please the dude who held up the envelope
and says i have evidence of collusion
and there was none it was like q anon
it's like you're some secret dude
reporting from a broom closet across
from the white house telling us any day
now it's going to happen right this is i
don't that's
man they're they're it's the two ends of
the same stick yep
but the the issue i suppose is you know
got queuing on people going on msnbc and
cnn or even fox news true maybe maybe
i'm sure there's some person who's gone
on fox news who said something about q
whatever it's probably been a while
though right
the the you look at the prominent um
right-wing voices or moderate or
libertarian voices and they're not you
you look at the left they're all blue
and on oh totally like 90 90 of them are
yeah not all of them do you mind telling
me what blue anon is or means
who that is yeah you know what q1 is
right yeah blue and on is a reference to
the democrats versions of insane
conspiracies like donald trump as a
russian agent same coin same same thing
okay but there's no person
claiming to be blue
okay like there's no queue either okay
yeah yeah stupid online forums or people
believe whatever but the blue anon
people are like any day now trump's
gonna get arrested and they post memes
of trump and handcuffs like being walked
out and they're like it's coming it's
coming yeah they have been screaming
that donald trump is gonna be arrested
for like four years now and
they're crazy conspiracy they also
believe that the 2020 election was
illegitimate that's right
isn't it fascinating everyone 2020 or
2016. oh 2016. i'm sorry everybody
thinks every election is illegitimate it
kind of it almost makes me feel like
maybe voting isn't always the best way
to solve our problems
michael malus had a bold tweet today he
was like there's there's no upside to
accepting an election you disagree with
well
like he's right i mean right in a sense
but i kind of feel like
accepting you lose an election is
because you have a stable system of
governance and a culture in which you
agree with people right i suppose if
we've we've come to the point in the u.s
where we have no unifying culture other
than gluttony
then
dependence we've got roads and currency
and education styles and communication
tele like i can drive to my parents
house in ohio i can you know we have a
lot of things binding us as a culture
but we have our culture as fracturing is
the issue yeah the internet has really
done that education let me
let me ask you guys right
uh let's say civil war happens the food
supply collapses because you know russia
and ukraine war
small town of ten thousand people what
do you think the people in that town do
when they run out of food
anybody well it depends on the town i
guess is it like out in the middle of
nowhere yeah growing their own food
there's a million or so
they're gonna have to go to the next
town and do what
look for food
so do you think the people in small town
will work together
to go look for food some of them will do
you think the town would start rioting
amongst its uh within itself and
destroying itself as people steal food
from their neighbors
possibly i don't think so
i think a small town of ten thousand
people in the middle of nowhere where
you're gonna have people come out like
what do we do
well i don't know we have no food you're
gonna have a town hall meeting there
might be some theft the police and
people will round up but we can't allow
this we got to figure this one out what
changes it is the internet because
you'll have like see sleeper cells on
facebook groups where they're like you
go and infiltrate your neighbor's
meeting and then we'll have an agent
there on thursday all these different
groups will come small town where people
are more likely to know each other
they're more likely to be conservative
they're more likely to go to church
together they're not going to break the
window of their neighbor's house to
steal his bread i think new york city on
the other hand their neighbors don't
know each other at all i lived below
above and across from people i never met
yeah i don't know their names i barely
knew what they looked like that's new
york city
out here we we know who the neighbors
are we only talk to them all that often
yeah but when you're out in the middle
of nowhere you're more likely to know
who your neighbors are i think
realistically in a small town setting
you're likely to see a handful of people
try to loot and riot and act crazy and
unfortunately you'll see some other
people in the town put them down
yeah
right they won't put up with it yeah i
think they would end that pretty quickly
and i wanted to say too i think this was
making me think that maybe part of the
reason that one in five people the
soviet union were informants by the end
was because they were living in such
close quarters because i was going to
say i was going to argue with tim and be
like oh no you know remember one in five
people you know people and families were
selling each other out but i was like
maybe that's because they were cramped
in like what was functionally good and
they were desperate yeah i mean
desperate to try to well not get thrown
in the gulag right but also to garner
goodwill with your superiors who have
their thumb on you
i think smaller towns
you're going to see a lot less rioting
yes and you do see a lot less riding in
general for you know for any reason
in new york where the guy who lives 10
feet from the other guy doesn't know
what the other guy is oh they're going
to rob you blind he's like i'm hungry
you got beans those beans are mine yeah
it's like i think it's called the
concept of anomie you know being
anonymous in a giant crowd because you
just can you can just blend right in
like a fish thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you